thank you yasser yes i'm here with uh
shakri arma medyarov
who just finished his game against uh
grishchuk chakriar first of all
welcome back to the show to the grand
chess tour how does it feel to be back
this is very nice to play in the board
and of course we all miss
to play chess and finally we start to
play
okay tournament start is not very well i
mean maybe some
boring draws i mean
but we will see i think in next games
next round so
interesting games do you feel like you
need a little bit of time to readjust
yourself to competitive over the board
chess does it feel different than
a year and a half ago of course of
course it's absolutely different
just different i don't know yesterday
i think in some moves
10 15 minutes normally i played these
moves in one minute and now i am not
absolutely sure about my moves
maybe i need some times to
to play some games and after some games
i think everything will back
absolutely so let's uh discuss a little
bit today's game
it looked very interesting at the
beginning take us through it okay
i i tried to play c4 c4 normally
of course i start to play d4 but
i analyzed this position for black
but but
he surprised me in opening and
i tried to play something very solid he
surprised you with this uh
opening i mean i mean yeah it's sasha
okay i mean
not easy play because he play normally
all lines
every time he try to play and he change
every time lines sometimes kings india
yeah sometimes and i play c4 but this
line of course uh i know it's solid
position for
white and it's everything is okay but
after here take take i think if i not
i'm sorry after d6 i think if not c5
move
he can play next c5 move or knight g4
uh okay i i i will say
you really i don't understand very well
this position and this was actually what
almira was mentioning that
after the normal h3 move black usually
has these five
i don't like because it's absolutely
long game and strategical game is bishop
g5 h6
bishop h positions like
you can play sometimes g5 bishop b6 is
long game
and i think it's better to play c5
and after c5 is everything looks like he
need to change something and
maybe if white need to play for win
c5 is not good move but if you want to
play normal
good chess i mean c5 is absolutely
normal move because after take
and take rookie one uh his problem
if after c5 he played knight g4 i can
play move
like bishop c4 is very interesting also
i don't know
it's bad movie but i missed some i mean
h4 i think first like what's the times
no queen h4 first queen yes oh this is
really nice he not played this move
yeah i i think it's a nice year for bad
move because bishop
bishop c4 yeah yeah but if knight g4
bishop c1 is in gnc
yes i think bishop c1 yeah absolutely i
think i bishop c4
i want to play and you're not worried
that you're going to lose a pawn yeah
because
yeah it looks strategically okay okay i
mean
after he take i play bishop c2
here bishop c2 and last uh
if take windy one maybe right is some
chance rook t1
and f6 rook d6 it is like neem service
possessions and
maybe is not easy to play with black and
white's adventure
but he take and queen d5 bishop c2 queen
c5
and queen h5 of course
yes if it's a checkmate because the skin
g6 is made
yeah and he plays just take and
and games that means after queen h5 g6
yeah g6 giving you back the pawn yeah
and it's a drop position
i also miss i miss uh bb show v6 move
windows
i miss we should be six movies very
strong because if you take on c6 then
yeah
i think he will if bishop d7 some
passive position maybe
like okay i can play long
[Music]
okay i mean some f3 rook d1 still
is not easy but uh he played bishop v6
and the absolutely instant
today is not my day and i need to play
draw
definitely the practical approach to the
tournament situation
getting back into gear of competitive
chess what are your ambitions for uh
this
tournament and your come back to jazz
okay after
i don't know one half year to say
something
i have big ambitions and i want to win
tournament no i just want to play chess
we need to time to back in normal chess
of course it's not easy tournaments is
to romanian chess grandmasters also is
very good
in severity you will see yesterday's
he got losing position yeah he sings
also i mean he's very strong tournament
sensor
two good grandmasters from romania is
also
very good i think it will be very nice
very interesting tournament
uh it will be more i think many surprise
games
also okay we'll see perfect thank you
very much uh shaq
and we're looking forward to your
combative style of chess to come back
and
give us some fire over the board guys
back to you in the studio